this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
so you can see the beautiful skies there
clouds are still everywhere and it's
nice and warm at the moment not too bad
good for the Predators and the thickness
of the bush here is where husana got
disappeared this morning a very very
good afternoon and welcome to the
beginning of the afternoon Safari
I am Sydney boomer anomie cozy and I'm
traveling with Michelle who is my camera
operator this afternoon we are going to
try by all means and get hold of a sauna
deep in this thick bushes is where we
left him earlier this morning and for
incase if you need our attention you can
follow us on Twitter hashtag Safari live
you can also follow us on YouTube chat
stream without any waste of time I want
to go back to where I have left him this
morning
so husana this morning it was
demonstrating some of his hunting
capabilities so chances of finding him
with a kill they are also very high he
was looking very hungry and he was
trying he was trying just that the prey
animals they were so very much clever
this morning amidst Steinbeck right in
front of us
so now let's cross over to the Maasai
Mara the David is ready to show you
something hello hello and a very good
afternoon from the Mara tryingo in Kenya
and thus a good yawn I'm not sure that
meant saying good afternoon to all of
you wherever you are in the world it's
very exciting to start our Sunset Drive
with two lionesses they are lets belong
to them all right and this is very close
to a cup and I'm sure nobody else
because my name and just in case my name
remains the same my name is David and
Archie is hidden camera Archie how are
you doing today we were excited to start
to lionesses right they're in such
gorgeous light well I'm sure Sidney told
you one very important thing that we
love questions who would love comments
because that one keeps us going and as
he told you hashtag Safari live on
Twitter just wonderful after we got here
about 24 degrees Celsius and 75 degrees
Fahrenheit and that feels very
comfortable for me and I would guess is
the same to these lions here they look
to like two youngsters or two young
males I'm looking at much better than
before in my monitor you can sit a bit
of Maine coming out to that neck this
must be two young boys who at a
particular age will always tend to be on
their own as I said earlier they're from
a pride that we called oh la la la la la
la is an escapement that is very close
to where we live and our cup is not very
far from
she just started coming down in this
government and this was our first stop
and how fast sighting it's gonna be a
good-looking day the way I feel it and
apart from myself and Sydney it is
another gentleman also would like to
stay jumbo and hello to all of you
thanks David good afternoon everybody
welcome to June at the sabi sands my
name is Steve I'm joined on camera by
hat and well it is a beautiful afternoon
little bit overcast not too hot but then
I did spin a little bit summer swimming
pool today which was fantastic we are
going to head up towards buffa sook Dam
there's potentially some tracks of ting
Ghana up there and well I haven't seen
the old boy in some time I'm sure you've
been told by David or Sydney how to get
hold of us hashtag Safari live or throw
your questions in on YouTube chat stream
remember the all-important FC @ FC keep
your questions relevant we'd love to
hear from you if any of you would like
to see tink on this afternoon well jump
on board we're gonna go see if we can
track him down he's been up in Buffalo
the last few days and well as we know
the juma is his dukedom and he will come
up and down and cover quite a large area
all the way into Torchwood Linda is the
power team on today we're all very
excited we've got a s ABC live TV show
after this Drive so we would like to
find some of our special characters to
show the people of South Africa who are
quite new viewers to the show show them
live on TV this afternoon evening which
I think will be marvelous what a better
way to start off David with a lion
Sydney if he can find the little chief
we know how popular the little chief is
he's got an agent and well whenever TV
rolls around we know him don't we he
can't get enough of the spotlight ting
Ghana well he is just a star in his own
right he might be a little bit old now
but still a very strong and courageous
gentleman
who I have not seen in some time and I'm
very excited to feast my eyes on him
again but anyway David is with an all a
lot old lioness let's go all the way
back up to the Maasai Mara and see
exactly what his lion is up to well I'm
very excited to hear Steve got plans of
looking for the Duke of jummah Tinga not
wish to be very exciting news and if you
do lunch
you'll make me a very happy gentleman in
Ghana is one level at a rush backed out
of his age and size and above all the
develop and Tigana would not compare to
these two young boys here I would say
this ones are just jokers compared to
the mighty and strong and very
good-looking thing Ghana but it will be
just a matter of time you know before
this boys also grow into size and you
can see wind is picking up and it's the
wind we picks up they gets not really
nervous but you can see their body and
language changes in the matter of
triangle we got so many prize of lions I
would get over 10 prides but the two of
them belong to the Hall of pride as I
said earlier and oh la la la is the
largest pride of lions that we got in
the Mara triangle and this is just two
of the sixteen strong alliance of this
particular pride one big advantage they
got is when they go for a hunt they
would be able to their even the very big
and dangerous prey I'm talking about
Buffalo's at two weeks ago they brought
two buffaloes down in a span of about
half an hour and in a radius of only a
hundred metres apart that was really
special and you know it was very cool
sighting to see like six my own son one
Buffalo and maybe ten on another Buffalo
this young Sathya I'm looking at there
maybe go into two years and for them to
be alone they are starting slowly
showing signs of independence and of
course they said two and a half
they'll be on their own
it's pretty windy but all goods the
light is just fantastic and behind them
that little tree line there this a small
natural stream and just society could
have been alia in there having a drink
but also where they are is quite a
vantage point because this cup meant he
just on the other side from them the
scum it's behind them and they're just
looking below this government and that
one gives them a good angle to see any
movement of prey down here
well the migration is gone I'm talking
about the wildebeest and most of the
zebras that one have seems to have a
little scar there if we look on the left
cheek he got a scar and I do not know
where he might have picked that scar
from so they carried a wound and it
could have been a Croma cord sheath muck
and so many things happen here out in
the wilderness well I spent a few more
minutes with these two boys and find out
what they're doing and I say do that
I'll turn you back again to South Africa
to Steve oh yes well we found a leopard
already and I decided to get out of the
vehicle and go and have a look he is a
tiny leopard tortoise let me just move
the stick out the way for you and then
you can see look at that now if you're
watching the show this morning we saw
some leopard tortoises getting a little
bit jiggy with it and well on this
legend gentleman is the buyer product
and this is still a relatively aged
tortoise they often are when they come
out babies their baths this small giving
a bit of a head there so the scoots each
of these is called a scoot and that's
the protective shell which is growing
season me with tortoises ed apparently
if you count the ridges the down and up
ridges those are the seasonal growths of
the animal and basically if you then
divide that by two you then get the age
so for example here one two three four
five six could you believe it that this
individual is possibly
years old the size of him
herbivores they feed on grass and
wherever they go is their home so he's
very cute he's not too bothered by us at
the moment I've moved this stick and he
obviously that is what tortoises do they
just walk in to a thicket plug
themselves down and the camouflage as
you can see is incredible so the
difference between this and the specs
tortoises you can see how sort of how
sorts of balls it is it's more of a cut
more of a dome than the specs which is
quite flat ladybird you don't know how
long they live for I think they can live
up to the 70s maybe even more than that
obviously different species of tortoise
can get to different ages or fella don't
go and get stuck in there now it's like
a four-wheel-drive machine just moving
through I'm thinking in the region of
between 70 and 80 years of age but there
might be other species of both that are
able to get older than that but the one
unique characteristic feature of this
very camouflage one is apparently
leopard tortoises are the only tortoise
that is able to actually swim I love
that fact but no cars disappeared and
that is what they do
he needs to hide there from all sorts of
predators and well if a sauna found this
of a guy that shell would probably small
enough and soft enough for him to break
needs to get much to very large ones
this morning well in comparison to that
one and maybe they are other parents
anyway great spot from cat very good
eyes grace did you say feisty little guy
okay now suppose tortoises are feisty
feisty little guy indeed okay just gonna
move out the way here we've got a bit of
a Herbie family grouping going on we're
just going to wave okay well
okay so we're gonna head up towards
bubbles with dam to see what we can find
because I mean 10 Ghana is in the area
and well you never know we might be able
to get in for the TV show this evening
that would be first-class but for now
back to David and his lion yes both was
Hawk tosses are you might see Scuba
Steve I'm not sure how much water was
having a dumb but to be happy to see
people they I know this two boys about a
month God trying to bring one or these
two but part of the young stars are the
young males in the Olerud pride tried to
hunt a hippo and I learned to adjust
jokers because he was very big and was
and rather dangerous you can see the
tail of one of them there
that's just rough from the back of the
brother and I guess these two young
stars are of the same litter the kind of
bonding they have they definitely must
be on the same mother and the same
father you can see the spots they are
still showing on that young one there
and is it just how we load up there's a
ticker fly on his tummy you can see how
his tummy is going to flies they're just
breathing but I would say the
temperatures pretty good to have a nap
so I'm not surprised wondering where the
other 14 would be and maybe the two boys
here are starting to fill his time they
excommunicated themselves from the 14
and start in their own life chances are
they might start their own coalition us
the two of them
noodle how are you and I gather you are
a new viewer and it's very excited to
have you on board and a very warm
welcome and just to let you know should
you not know we'll always have two
drives one in the morning and one in the
afternoon
both from Kenya and in South Africa well
most of us have different origins and
different trainings but the most
important noodle we all have a
background in world life studies we have
done our word life from college and we
have trained in different fields so what
life is whole thing and we do not only
deal with outside animals we also do a
lot of flora so Steve for example is
very good when you talk of botany so
that's a background for all of us we
love what we're doing and we have all
been trained to be in the African
wilderness thank you very much for
joining us make sure you always stay
with us so if you just joined us now
these two youngsters or these two lions
here belongs to the olala pride and all
our pride is the largest pride in the
Mara Triangle noodle and of course all
the other viewers remember your
questions and your comments give us lots
of joy so keep sending us questions and
noodle that was a good question to know
the background of all the wildlife
guides so buying in the bush or biology
is our stuff so most of us have lunch
botany
because we need to know what our animals
are made of ideally all of us a
naturalist because we have grown with
this animals and this is where we are we
are here on daily basis except when we
break and go home for a couple of days
to see your families or have a little
break just to breathe and reload of US
House and Reno joyous and then we come
right back and that's how we end up
doing these lions we can tell them by
face we can tell you the numbers if we
see one or two missing will Elias will
always let you know three of them were
missing five four missing because we
know all of them we leave them them
every other day so give you one more
quick look noodle and over there the
viewers of these two boys here because
we are going to move on I want to go
look
for maybe the rest of the parade and
find out where the other 14 are I still
believe they are not independent enough
to be away from their mothers or the
auntie's and cousins so it's just a sign
of teenage you know we can be away then
back to the fold we can vary than box
therefore maybe after a few other times
they'll be gone and they'll have their
own life see the black spots on the ears
there the black marks in the ears which
sometimes we see the use us follow me
sign when they walk through the grass
they had his dollars up and you can only
see the black marks I don't the es or
sometimes when they keep flicking their
tails up well my friend Sydney in South
Africa is so determined to get a leopard
for all of us let's find out how he such
is going I am right now in the middle of
one of the drainage lines where we left
Hosanna here this morning and I'm just
trying to carry on from previous he
might be somewhere around the same area
it was a really late when we left him
normally it doesn't travel that much
when the Sun is getting stronger
so the speeders are so very quiet a lot
of animals I am relying on everyday they
have very quiet at the moment so this is
the area where he was hunting a
Steinbach this morning
he likes the big drainage earlier the
area here is the area where I saw him
playing with the elephant dung some time
ago he likes this place yeah that
sighting took place somewhere here so
this is one of his special preferences
so he must be lying down somewhere in
this Kali here but I'm not going to give
up I'm going to look for him until we
find it
Catherine it is so beautiful indeed
everything is green at the moment and
this green color is the one which can
easily hide the spotted hassanein so
it's disappearing in between these
bushes
so now let's quickly go back to Steve
and hear what he is having at the moment
thanks it is talking about the little
chief asana I remember early this year I
was driving down this exact same road
over here and I came around the corner I
think I was talking about we really want
to find a leopard now and we came around
the corner and we found him looking at
his reflection in this little pan little
green pan just to the right of the
screen there and it was really quite
funny we followed him after that and
then we got him killing a scrub here so
you know we can actually spend some time
on this Drive as well reminiscing and
all the places we found these
interesting animals because always the
antics that they they carry out while we
watch them is always quite funny I
remember finding him he was just looking
quite said his reflection just like that
was before here in turn is on his
walkabout remember he went away was just
before that yeah he is a clown but we
love him very much
we love him very much but the reason why
we're checking is little water muddy
pans it's exactly that the cats like to
come and drink and quite often you can
find them in and around close to where
the water is and it's one of the reasons
why this time of year it's quite tricky
to find cats because oh well there's an
Egyptian goose who's a little bit
confused maybe he wants to go to that
little water pond as well it's lost his
mate very quiet so this must be the male
I say that in jest
he's gay it's going to come over to a
little Maddy Maddy pond over there so
the animals obviously need to drink
everyday but when there's an abundance
of water all over the place they don't
have to go very far and seeing Egyptian
geese goose this far away from permanent
water is very very interesting obviously
going to new pastures or maybe going out
on it on a tinder date maybe was
swapping was told to come and meet by
the pan maybe it's for sauna playing a
trick and trying to ambush this
individual goose by luring him in to a
pan where can you say that okay
images made a joke so it's known by
Egyptian goose as a gimbal not a tinder
very clever Emma very clever
so anyway maybe Hassan is trying to lure
this goose out on a promise of a grassy
meal some seeds thrown in it as well we
know Egyptian geese are grazes and they
quite enjoy a couple of the seeds off of
the grasses and it's walking very
precariously towards the thickets there
it's not a really good idea if you ask
me very interesting note that a desire
on its own I'm not going to say that am
i no ok straight to this little water
puddle yes therefore this could very
likely be
vasanas Christmas duck or he could have
already had the other one because as you
all know ladies and gentlemen who
watched show all the time Egyptian goose
is in fact a duck which is a very
strange because gooses are supposed to
honk and ducks are supposed to quack and
well if you've ever heard an Egyptian
goose make a noise there's absolutely no
honking in oh no quacking in that at all
it's all very definitely coming to the
water maybe accan knows the waters yet
might feel quite safe there who knows
sorry I haven't positioned you very well
there my reverse
skills this afternoon or something to be
not something to be desired
anyway the thing with going out in
search of a cat is we are spending time
out in the wilderness so they are tracks
they are Birds
we had a very brief visual of a quite a
large flock of red-billed quelea switch
I wanted to show you quickly because
it's the first ones of the season that
up see that is not what I want to show
you first runs of the season and they
are according to certain David
Attenborough accumulate in the largest
flocks of bird known to man and there is
the breeding plumage of the male just
try get that the angle of the light
how's that it's very beautiful and
accumulate in hundreds of thousands of
birds obviously the small flock we saw
just now was only about fifty maybe but
they accumulate enormous flocks and
they're migratory throughout the country
they don't really go in a much further
north on a proper migrant just sort of
like a an altitude noir migrant if for
once of a better word right now and they
feed on seeds and they are waiting for
the rainfall and they will accumulate in
very large colonies generally in in very
sort of stunted nob thorn vegetation
where they'll have their nests and
hundreds of thousands of birds will nest
there huge amounts of seed are ingested
by them daily as they go into the
feeding grounds and they are the food of
stalks marabou storks lesser spotted
Eagles they feed thousands and thousands
of predators that come and feed just on
them and you just walk around the base
or come as a very interesting looking
Nala you just have to stop for five
minutes out there and the animals will
the geese and the new Allah's will just
pop out it comes a boy about across the
road and this is very characteristic in
Yolo fashion
beautiful young man is on his own I
don't know well in saying that you've
spent five minutes with an Jana and
suddenly you see six and seven come out
of the thickets and that is exactly the
strategy they have to move in and
disappear lending in with the
environment but the queriers feed on
enormous amounts of seed and around the
base of the trees is huge amounts of
obviously droppings
seed dispersal as well and those trees
get boosted with a huge amount of
nitrogen big nutrient recycling big seed
dispersal and well they are well known
on the African continent as a pest to
farmers but in essentially the quelea
was here first and so we need to live
with him but unfortunately they are well
are destructive to people who grow seed
bearing crops anyway enough about that
we're gonna move on a seat if we can
find you some other animals along the
way but as we do move along all sorts of
things pop up and well we're not just
going to find in Ghana we're gonna find
you whatever comes along as I said
through your tweets we would love to
hear from you but in the meantime David
do too I think is still with his lion in
the Mara and I don't think it's raining
today very good to see Angela and even
better to see elephants with calves look
at that smaller family of elephants
there and what I'm feeling I'm feeling a
bit of a feeling a bit of where Spitz
coming to me and I'm not sure we are
going to get a strong anytime now and if
they look to overclock from where I am
Luke about Tom you just carry that and
that's very very dark well so far so
good
and I'm getting some wonderful showers
as I am but hopefully I got a feeling
that this range will just come and fast
but as it is now it's just starting to
fall and what am I want to do now M it's
maybe to bring the covers down we've got
a very expensive equipment in the car
and you can see the rain if you move to
the right Archie you can see that huge
wall of rain in the background
that is about a kilometer away from
where we are and that is the Masai Mara
for you we are having the short trains
which I don't think I short trains so
what we'll do for now I'll first in-use
back to Sydney and you're gonna monitor
the situation and see how it goes
then I'm sure at one point you'll be
back with me Sydney
Leicester stall what's your update
enjoying quite a lot of rain by the
Maasai Mara as it is raining almost
every day these days there and here we
are still hoping to get more rain so
apologies for that I am right on the
main road which is a drivable by anybody
so this is the area where I am going to
try my luck but I can't find any office
and Astrix coming out of the block from
Juma to their buffers who I'm right now
on the borderline
jennipher girl the biggest challenge
when looking for hosana specifically the
area where i am now is the drainage
lines they or the dry riverbeds this old
dry riverbed some of the areas are not
easily accessible even by the four by
fours so that is the biggest challenge
when looking for this cat by this side
of the game reserve so when in the
drainage you cannot see him until you
drive along parallel to the drainage
line is when you can see if it's lying
down in the middle some of these
drainage drainage lines we can be able
to drive inside them
so I am very sure now that he is still
much more decide I didn't see any of his
tracks coming out towards the buffers
book and it's only few animals yeah way
I am maybe is due to his presence in the
area
so now let's quickly go back to Steve
who is good
Abed yes well I must apologize for
jinxing David with my last link sending
him all all the way back up to the Mara
said it was not raining and now I have
brought the rain very powerful words
that I apologize David
but anyway down here in drew mur it is
not raining but I wonder all of you bird
enthusiasts out there that have been
watching the show for a long time same
two answers about what bird this might
be the colors aren't that great right
now because of the light but very easy
to understand what it is if you're not
short same through hashtag Safari live
or what a bird is this let's see he
couldn't be first on the button wait for
your answers but what is interesting is
it's part of a family of birds that live
in cavities in trees and so the tree
that it's on is a dead tree that's
either been killed by elephants or maybe
even a porcupine damaged in over time it
has died and many many species of bird
actually use cavities in nests of trees
that have been created by the burrows or
by excavations for beetle larvae and by
woodpeckers and barbets so many birds
then live in those cavities in the trees
where there then rear their chicks and
this bird has to compete with lots of
other birds for those nesting sites very
very nice to see one of the prettiest of
the birds we have archaea once again a
pretty bird with not a very nice voice
hopefully it will turn for us and show
us its face Vicki and Andrew you've got
at hundred percent right I wonder if
anyone else is going to get it right and
then we'll give the answer don't want to
give the answer way too quickly but it
is an insect eating bird catches most of
it either on the wing key heart is not a
woodpecker but it is a family birds that
have just landed just below it they're
family of white Kristin helmet tracks
have landed on the tree they're doing a
bit of
cleaning be hard is not a woodpecker is
a bird that catches insects either by
flapping onto the ground on them or or
in aerial pursuit but doesn't create the
holes itself woodpeckers are known for
making the holes they create the
cavities which are bird like this who's
very hot you can see his beak is open is
cooling down Chris it is not a European
ruler you are on the correct family
their European role is very blue in
color this bird has got a very
distinctive arbor are striped you see
that very distinctive white stripe on
the eye you can see the long beak with a
little tip at the end is very
characteristic of the roller family and
while you see the tail the tail is got
it kind of just ends abruptly so it is
not the common lilac breasted roller and
which has got sort of Lolich on the
breast and all sorts of other colors it
is the family favorite one of my
favorite birds indeed whose being while
enjoying a little bit of time with some
fellow friends that is the purple roller
the biggest of the road of species and
well it makes a very funny noise would
you like to hear it have a listen to
this chimpanzee in the sky how crazy is
that I think is a very interesting call
purple roller but an insect eating bird
they flop down onto the floor to catch
their insects or catch them on the wing
where as you can see the white Chris at
helm attracts their jumping through the
branches they're very agile and they do
a lot of what we call gleaning of
insects if you don't probably different
species of insects different areas
within the tree but they're able to
access sort of areas that the rollers
are not able to you often find their
owners perched conspicuously out on the
end of a branch now where is these
beautiful beautiful white helmet racks
white crested helmet racks who are a
family unit they move through the tree
in unison
leaning and picking insects off almost
working like a dolphin family would
assisting each other in rearing the
chicks and collecting the food scenic I
have seen all of the South African
roller species and they are very very
special Bunch
and I've got them all here for you on my
phone I can once you just pan out there
you can have a look they are probably
one of the coolest family of birds next
to the bee-eaters with regards to
coloration and also that Soraka as I
suppose here we have on the top we've
got the very blue European roller then
underneath that is the very blue but
with long spatulate advisors underneath
is the racket-tail you find those up in
the northern kruger national park and
very common in zimbabwe up here is the
very common racket and lilac breasted
see the streamers on the end of the tail
which make it different from the the
purple roller which is flat at the end
then one of the coolest ones to see is
the broad bald it's got a very purple
body very yellow bright contrasting beak
and then at the bottom the biggest of
the species the purple roller so those
are the five that we see and I've
actually seen all five of them on one
walk in the Macaulay key area in
northern Kruger National Park so if you
are an avid birder for savanna bird
species the northern kruger national
park is where you have to go racket-tail
runners are there we one of my favorite
places to go to
oopsy let's get started
had a lady burped our we do indeed get
swans in Africa but I don't think any of
them are indigenous I think they're all
imported from North America or Europe
I'm not 100% sure if they came from
North America but possibly from Europe
but not indigenous pretty much in every
sort of pond and lake we have in sort of
suburbia of South Africa you will find
geese and swans doing all sorts of
things
they've all been imported of course and
well the kids love to feed them bread
crumbs and wherever there's a park or a
play area with some form of water well
you'll find lots of these birds my uncle
actually used to have a few swans at his
house and they were the best security
guard dogs or pets they used to chase
any intruder that came into the garden
and they can be very aggressive and they
could bite quite painfully as I
experienced once on my bottom I never
liked going to my uncle's house after
that
he beat me on the bottom that's what
happened okay
so this is an area right here that I've
had Tandy many many times going up this
road now this is drakensberg Road named
after the joggers who bounces that you
can normally see it but today there are
some clouds so we won't even try to show
you just off yet
not far away is our eastern boundary
with tortured but this area here on the
right is an area that while we've had
Tandy and Columba sort of in the the
five six month area of when Flambeau is
five six months old she was here often
that was the stage when Haku moody had
moved into the area and was sort of
moving in on the western side of Jummah
and tani kind of moved this side because
it's in Ghana was kind of a little bit
frail at the time ago if there's some
bouts of illness he had a little
sabbatical and well who Komori was
around doing his thing on the west and
Tandy was here very very often and so
hopefully we'll be able to bump into one
of these individuals this afternoon but
while we are moving along there's so
much more to see and to do and talking
about rollers here is the much more
common of the species and you'll be able
to see the very characteristic streamers
on the bottom of the tail which will
make it much easier to identify then the
purple roller that we saw and this is
the very common and most photographed
bird in the Kruger National Park look at
the streamer on the end of the tail that
Finan band this is the lilac breasted
roller the national bird of Kenya and
David Gita's favorite bird as well
there's a Hannah bird that looks as if
you've given a child a color in drawing
and they've taken every ridiculous color
imaginable and put them together
beautiful beautiful the Afrikaans name
is called a throw punt which basically
means a wedding band and it is well
known to take a lilac breasted roller
feather and to wrap it in a ring and to
basically give it to your betrothed as a
promise for what is to come in the
future which i think is very interesting
and up in Zimbabwe back in the days
before it was Zimbabwe long time ago
there was a chief up there of the mutter
bel-air people called
lobbying Gulen who was of Zulu origin
they moved up many many many years ago
in the 1800s and well it was his color
his feather of choice and if any one
tried to adorn themselves with the lilac
breasted roller feather he would have
his head chopped off so from a very nice
match burnheal ceremony in the Afrikaans
culture to beheadings it sounds a little
bit like Henry the eighth right yeah but
anyway enough of my babbling you're
gonna keep on going up this road yeah
which is going to wind us although a / -
bazooka dam in the Northeast and
hopefully as it starts getting cooler we
might be able to find ting Ghana Mike
there are plenty of insects Archer that
are poisonous and generally poisonous
insects have got coloration that is
bright and contrasting blacks with
yellows oranges with blacks those sort
of contrasting colors that make them
stand out the the monarch butterfly is a
very good example their larval phase of
Caterpillar actually takes in a toxic
plant called milkweed and that then
leads to the adults being poisonous and
there's lots of other insects out here
that if ingested could kill us but a lot
of the birds have actually evolved to
either deal with it or because the
colors are so bright and contrasting to
avoid them altogether and when talking
about the monarch butterfly there is a
species of monarch butterfly called let
me remember hyper luminous Mississippi's
how did I remember that I don't know but
I can't even remember the common name
but that scientific name is etched in
there and they mimic the monarch
butterfly and it is a term known as the
Bayesian mimicry now mimicry is when you
mimic something to benefit yourself now
if all of the hyper luminous
mississippi's butterflies had to mimic
sorry I'm not trying to sound smart by
saying that long word it's just the only
name I can remember right now I will
come back with it if all of them had to
mimic the minute we'll just frame this
other bird over here while I continue to
talk my nonsense they got a magpie or
long-tailed Shrike over here so if all
of the hype aluminous
species had to mimic the monarch
butterfly well there's a good chance
that a birds gonna taste one and realize
it's not poisonous so by teasing mimicry
means 25% of the population so 25% 50%
being female 50% being male and 25% in
total it would be females of that
species have the same coloration as the
monarch butterfly the males I actually
quite sort of white with necessary black
with white spots very easy to identify
and while they're not poisonous at all
but the females happen to get by by
looking like a poisonous individual that
is hence why we know birds can seek a
lap because not only do they have
feather adornments but they also can see
fruits which are needed to obviously you
want to eat ripe fruits and you don't
want to eat a poisonous insect because
if you do well either make you very sick
or you will die and as you know most
animals through survival of the fittest
have learnt that dying is not the way
forward if you want to well keep on
living but anyway we've got wonderful
birds this afternoon I'm talking a lot
of nonsense but that's okay we're going
to go to David who is sheltered from the
rain and hopefully also from the storm
well here we are and if you look through
there that's the situation we are in now
and it's not raining here I would say
dogs and cats but it's raining elephants
and buffaloes if you got through not
sure whether anything can go through
here but at the very end there at one
point just one minute
I try and clear this and he put
something you put some elephants there
ha ha ha so heavy rain but
yeah now but CPU
expand review
chicking the whole cupboard reify now
we're gonna wait tight be back in action
so let's really we open that side where
the Archie can see anything just fallen
for a minute
Akagi this is wonderful
I see let's see where they can see
anything from here yeah okay there
I had my Pia earpiece off and that's the
situation we are in now in the mara
triangle it's heavy
heavy rains and they apparently meant to
be the short rains but to me they feel
they look and they sound even bigger
than the long rains we had in June July
August but again this is Africa this is
the kind of weather we go through it has
been very erratic the last couple of
years not very far from where we are we
had those two lions on fire
and I think about 100 metres from here
we go to the front of elephants we saw
before but at the moment we're gonna
remain in this kind of situation until
the rains subsided and how beautiful is
this I'm just enjoying it thundering the
canvas top of a barn so you can see it
and the intensity is getting bigger and
bigger which means big fun elephants
should not be affected by this rain
because they still keep grazing and rim
what they need to do well we think we
may have to get you across with me
a David is enjoying some rain and now he
is on a shower break maybe the time in
combat I will be having the beautiful
cat already some checking back again by
the Gallagher pen because this is the
only nearest dam in the area I'm sure is
going to come and drink here
so the squirrel was just complaining now
but I saw that the squirrel were
complaining about the presence of one of
the Raptors in the area so they were
against one of the Raptors
so when this animals are against Hassan
or Ching Ghana you will hear also the
antelopes not only just the bed but if
it's just the best then it means
something small normally their own
predator
daily I have never seen the meerkat in
Juba I'm not too sure if it's one of
those animals who are all caring here
because there is different kind of small
animals that we see some we don't see
very often so the Juma Game Reserve
defenses has been taken down it is
connected with all the other areas all
the way down to the Kruger National Park
so sometimes we do see the rare animals
entering this area
so the meerkats are very much rare is
something which is very very difficult
and to find you don't have to be very
lucky to see the meerkats I have never
operate so the mierqis they do have free
daters but mostly you will see them as a
mob and they do protect each other
normally when it comes to the animals
such as snakes you will see they can
easily mobilize and charge that snake
they do kill snakes
so no one is around the pen at the
moment Nina they are like the dwarf
mongoose and they've got similar kind of
the behavior because you'll see the
normal stand up red staining and
binocular vision in check and check and
they do make quite a lot of noise if
they are not happy or when they see a
predator such as neighbours they do make
noise
so the the banded mongoose I have seen
them here in Juma the other day I was on
a guided walk and they were all just
migrating from a big termite mound very
quickly but it was a good sighting I
have seen the Barry Mongoose here before
so these are the suitable areas for
these animals to hide when is too hot
this big drainage lines
so here sometimes the Lionel's they also
come as well they like this drainage
Paula the Mongoose I have never seen
them combining normally I see specific
species working together as a as a troop
but to see them mingling is very much
rare a report abilities of inbreeding if
they mingle they are very much higher
animals they do interpret if they
staying together or whereas their
different species
mic the Maasai Mara is over thousand
kilometres away from where we are so the
weather on the other side there is
different from where we are at the
moment but if you check also here the
clouds is overcast possibilities of us
to have rain as well
tonight they are also very much high we
might compete for the rain this evening
but so far the Maasai Mara is getting
quite a lot of rain
it is raining there now very often so
now let's quickly go back to Steve
welcome back we are still on drakensberg
just having a little listen quickly
rickson's talking to me on the radio if
you just give me one moment standing by
rekhs someone drakensberg you wants to
know where I am
yeah now someone else is getting very
confused think we're talking to them
okay well that's not for me there's a
whole different conversation going I do
apologize there's another guy on the
property called sips and Stephen sips
they kind of became very similar there
there and now that the confusion is out
the way
David is enjoying himself in the rain
that are provided for him thanks David I
do apologize no doubt it'll be a quick
downpour and then it'll be gone again
we hope do you hope anyway we're
continuing up on our eastern side we
will be getting towards before sook
watching Hall in a little bit taking it
slowly having a little listen and a look
around there's glory pan coming up on
the left oh there is a 3rd roller
species this is the European roller on
the right hand side sorry about my
brakes there you can see the very blue
coloration and almost I am indeed on a
roll doosh there was a drum roll indeed
thanks Emma so the European roller which
comes to South Africa this time of year
form for feeding they don't come and
breed at all so there's no competition
between them and the other roller
species for the tree cavities and they
also arrive here competing for insects
though of course you see how they're
conspicuously perched on the end of the
branch there but they come here and
they're a silent they are silent
visitors to South Africa because there's
no point in making a noise and expending
energy in that regard if you are not
breeding most birds that create noise
and make all sorts of songs and do all
sorts of display as well they all try
and to demarcate territory for the
purposes of having youngsters obviously
either the more defensive orders of
great oh hello yawn well the greater the
display might be or the most beautiful
song well the bigger the Terauchi or the
more ladies you might have so you can
see the riders will sit on the end of a
branch and use very good eyesight to
look for any insect that but me moving
around on the ground and then they'll
flop down on it Adele you say we've got
beautiful birds I think we have some of
the most gorgeous birds in the world
I would like to go birding all over the
world though to be able to compare but
once you start birding somewhere it is a
passion you can take with you anywhere
because well the world society of
birding has become very very well and
truly United and the roller is a roller
siroccos at Soraka so if you have seen a
roller before and you see a bird that
you've never seen before but kind of has
the same characteristics as the roller
well guaranteed it is one you just need
to find the local area and bird species
and have a look so you've noticed we've
seen three but our oldest today the
shape the form the everything about them
really apart from a bit of color is very
very similar and that is why they have
been grouped into the same group but
where the name roller actually comes
from is in their display rollers when
they are demarcating or fighting over
territories and in this form it is
looking for tree cavity holes for
nesting they will do these up and down
sort of diving bombarding dives which
end in a sort of left and a right wing
going up in a barrel sort of roll up and
down and it is very very traumatic for
other birds to experience of course
because they get chased away but
obviously the male with a better diving
role is more dominant than another one
and what ladies are looking for all
sorts of things like that aren't there
just look how he uses his wings what a
marvelous fellow and then we're in the
birding Kingdom most of the time it is
the ladies who choose most of the time
beautiful that is three rollers today if
I manage to get you a broad bull roller
well I'll do a backwards somersault on
the spot how's that I will
and we'll try helps right ah giraffe
girl now when you talk about the top of
the list that means of birds that I
still want to see okay that is it
I'm on 619 South African birds now and
there is a bird there two birds one that
comes to mind immediately a lot of
people who know me know it African Peter
is a bird that I have not managed to see
it an old student of mine is in Zimbabwe
I'm going to find it for you and he sees
it regularly and posts pictures and
teases me not very nice is he
Luke wherever you're out there I'm
talking about you let me find this pizza
for you African pizza okay let me show
it to you it's a beautiful bird really
is a beautiful bird there it is there
how's that beautiful coloration and it's
a forest specialist there are lots of
records of them in South Africa but
there's no sort of set area where you
will find them but Zimbabwe much more
common to see they got this very
characteristic way of sort of standing
with their back to you and then doing
this interesting sort of jump up and
flap when I was doing some training in
Malawi years ago my last day the
students that I was training actually
surprised me
they wanted to do a surprise lunch and
they didn't know how to get me there and
so they set up the surprise lunch around
the corner and then there came running
and see quick quick we've got an African
pizza I came running and I ran headlong
into all of the students there to say
farewell in heaven last lunch it was it
was very sweet but I was very
disappointed I didn't see the pattern I
was before I start there let's have a
listen to this core because it is quite
unique
it doesn't that's stopped for some
reason it jumps up into the air have you
seen my hat how does it see one okay oh
it's not the coolest call in the world
obviously I want to see when it ended
here one but common in Zimbabwe and
there are records of them all over the
eastern side of South Africa but not for
me yet we all get one you get one the
bird list continues Dell we do we do get
lots of finches fire finches they are at
least two species that we should get in
this area that Jamison and the red world
fire finch in the forest areas you'll
get the African fire fitch possibly
possibly get it here sometimes in sort
of more thicker areas then sort of up in
and the more dry areas of the Kalahari
you get the scaly feathered Finch
there's a very cool bird called a
cutthroat trench
you don't I've never found one here I
found them up in the north of Kruger
it's a little whitish bird with the red
line across the neck and the name is
quite easy to understand cutthroats it
looks like it's been severed the neck
very cool here we are at gory pan so
there's a lot of finches a lot of
finches I can't tell you all of them off
the top of my head now lots of wax bulls
and finches here is the next paddlin pan
where many times Tandy and Colombo have
been seen so we're just going to be
checking all these areas for tracks
maybe if we spend enough time here we
will get a couple finches coming down
let me see if I can quickly find a page
of finches cut yeah I'll show you the
cutthroat finch really quickly before
you run off to david let's quickly have
a look at the cutthroat finch and then
you're going to leave with that red line
that crosses through it he is bleeding
out for don't worry he's going to
survive
let's hope David survives the rain Billy
yes this is where I am this is where
Archie is and this is where we are the
good news we are surviving and we are
enjoying every minute as I said earlier
is fooling elephants and buffalos and
Archie's telling us we need to change
that and get something more serious than
that
but either way we got elephants just
passed us here a few minutes ago which
were not worried of the rain so we are
going to remain here until things get
better still raining hopefully we'll
wait until things get better and what
will happen is you know it just drops at
one point when we left the camp alia it
looked so clear so good as talking to em
in the final control and just me how
does however look clear sky blue - so
clear but all of a sudden now Pooh I
couldn't believe it
so the good news is at one point it
might stop so I will not live here I'll
stay here just making sure I don't get
stuck because this is one time you make
a mistake and the geology of the mara if
you look at the soil we have watch put
the black cotton soil which could be
very tricky so a heavy car like this the
cat's office have you going to take you
back to the rain the catch off is heavy
and
he's
and it read it aloud you kidding
yourself and you might have to get a
grader to get you up to the game Rangers
will be very happy asking you what do
you think you are doing their hours
hopefully
you
Shawn temperature that could be too cold
for ions I'm looking at anything below
10 but somehow they have always managed
to adopt them selves Shawn and it gets
very cold you see lions culling
themselves and just tucking themselves
in and holding just to keep their body
temperatures going not once we have seen
prides of lions coming together next to
each other well it's very cold but
somehow in Africa we have never seen I
mean lions are shown suffering because
of cold temperatures but out gets
anything below 10 would be a bit of a
worry even for us as human beings as
much as we shall always know what's due
to air one or two layers anything below
10 to 10 10 degrees Celsius could be a
bit of a concern for ions well you can
see the amount of water that's raining
there so what you've done we brought the
flaps down roto SH wind shield up and
just staying here resting and talking
stories of rain new gachi and I'm
telling him how I used to like the rain
one over your small boy and he's saying
he doesn't care about the rain with the
choice he doesn't want even to see it
for me
it looks pretty good so let me see Mike
a little turn around here but they have
to be very careful they will do one
small mistake who may be stuck here for
the next couple of hours and the
challenge would be to get someone to
come and tell you out because they'll
wonder how do we get there you know so
people will be like we'll see you later
or they'll wants to come with a game
Ranger with a gun for example and make
us walk to their car or where they know
they're safe and they take us back to
the camp
and they'll tell us we shall come back
here tomorrow to get the car I don't
think we want to do that what you want
risk too of course fingers as much as we
want the rain and hopefully it's going
to subside maybe after that 10-15
minutes who knows but sometimes you know
we have to take it as it comes
four eyes feel a little bit chilly but
that's fine
[Applause]
we just want to change the angle
director because we've got water coming
in the car we don't what
giraffe girl I'm not sure whether your
question was what's the best weather
I've been in was that a question from
giraffe da da da da Qi the commercial
okay there's a custom from giraffe girl
there
just bring it again yes and that's good
this way and you won't sue the weather I
have been in ah keep going on like Egon
okay a giraffe go through this an angle
I wanted a she's always very particular
on the angles he likes in terms of
shooting well there's so many weathers
have been here and I think the wash
would have been in was in the middle of
this year we had massive rains and was
raining so very heavily and was not good
because we only had to stay on the big
doors you see like the can you see
passing there definitely there's some
guests in and you can see they are
running back to the camp because they
know bein out here it will not help them
they cannot see any animals and you
cannot leave the big road to try and
venture away from the road you see
everybody's just now going back home and
nobody won't take any chances but again
as I say giraffe girl me and Archie are
not going anywhere
so May June July I know you can hear any
thunderstorms there so those
thunderstorms giraffe girl are the ones
that sometimes give us a bit of a
concern or worry because we may have to
power down with such an expensive
equipment to that we surely have in the
car
we fear laitanan could be sometimes a
big concern rain doesn't worry us so
much but the lessening and the
thunderstorms are always a bit of a
concern well a drop got many thanks for
your question and always very happy to
hear you but a giraffe car and there the
viewers why don't you entertain you more
with a car twin Steve oval
we're gonna do the tingitana dance we're
gonna do the tingitana dance look at
what we found 10 Ghana the Juke of Juma
well we set out looking for him he had
been in before sook in the north
herbie had tracks of him coming in south
we picked drakensberg road and well we
have been fortunate
Rickson the other gentleman who works at
via teller was in the area and then he
happened to come across him so we were
in the right area at the right time but
he is on a very particular route I know
this route quite well I followed him
along this before Ventura verse back
keep up with him exactly where I spoke
about Tandy five minutes ago or so when
I started rambling I that might have
been at the beginning of the drive this
is where Tenggara is now exactly on that
spot so he's walking straight down as
chokings burger road this is a road of a
hill called led word which I followed
him on a number of times and what he did
those last couple times it just have a
look you there right there that what he
did that twice two times that I followed
him as he crossed in to chitwa because
this pathway will take it straight it
should trap but he crossed just since
the other side it looked down towards
the dam sat down by the pan and just
started calling to the world and then he
stood up and walked parallel road and
then went into tortured so it was very
special
let's have spent time with him then that
Rene it was just coming back he was
still limping he wasn't looking in good
form but he was giving it everything in
with regards to the territorial calling
and well now he is on another walk this
is what they will do regularly after
rainfall to remark and resent mark the
areas that they have claimed to be
theirs and investigates the presence of
new females investigate the occurrence
of what have you spotted there boy you
see the body language change
I can't see what he's seen but he's
running off to something let's go and
have a look
Eagle Scout he does look hungry
sorry I'm just dropped okay he's just
run into the thickets they're not sure
exactly what he's seen what's he got
there eggs okay so that niala we saw
earlier that wasn't looking very healthy
he seems have spotted him so we're just
going to give him a moment Durex can see
him we don't want to influence they want
that the Duke to win necessarily or the
New Orleans will necessarily can you see
him Rex okay so then y'all is very close
I'm just gonna move up a couple meters
so that we can maybe get him in maybe
get him in frame
every guy he's just yeah okay that's
just it just moving out the way we've
got another vehicle on the way yeah
Rosemarie is definitely making well at
the moment he's keeping to a very normal
sort of territory line but now he is
looking to maybe catch some food but
most certainly Emma if you'd like to
invite some more viewers onboard we
don't know where this could go
he could most certainly catch this niala
I haven't seen than Jana he saw
something very camouflaged Erickson
spotted it told me there's an e I love
it oh and this
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
welcome to trimmer
private game reserve in the sabi sands
South Africa we've just framed up a
hyena for you it is not what we in the
citing for we have got a big male
leopard just here in front of us by the
name of King Ghana he is the Duke of
Jummah and he has spotted a what we
believe to be a frail-looking Nala some
way hidden there in the thickets
anything could happen right now please
feel free to send any comments and
questions you might have food to hash
tag sapphire larval dropped him in on a
YouTube chat stream below we'd love to
in the comment section below I mean I'd
love to hear from you his intention this
is the reigning Duke the reigning
dominant leopard of this area he's been
up in the north after summer rainfall he
is now filing the need to move through
his territory indie market through st.
marking the rainfall has washed away the
scent that he's laid down but along
these long one drinks he gets quite
hungry I'm not going to move we are in
the sighting with other vehicles but I
don't want to disturb him or vignola
each individual needs to have their fair
chance and well leopards as we think are
very successful but the camouflage stuff
and alertness of the antelope animals is
very very good and well they often avoid
being caught when they're on their own
sometimes it's quite tricky Ramat you
want to know how far away it is I can't
quite see it at the moment there's a
vehicle behind us that ahead in fact
seen it we're just having a look through
the thickets now I'm gonna look with my
binoculars because I'm in a slightly
different position to hat on the back
he's going to go for it sooner Yamato so
quickly just introduce ourselves
hello my name is Steve joined by hats on
camera and well the man of the hour is
right here ahead of us Joan is he a
loner lipids lipids are loners actually
you don't find lipids with other lipids
generally males stick to themselves
females to themselves unless they have
Cubs but the hierarchy that happens
Archer in Douma private game reserve we
are seeing some incredible scenes of
late with well the smell lipid stealing
from his son the smelly but stealing
from his previous girlfriend and while
having interactions with a year old cub
as well so the dynamics here are
incredible
well we documented okay so we're just
watching his body language Thomas you
wanna know if leopards are more
successful at hunting than other cats
well lions and leopards have invariably
got roughly about a twenty percent
success rate when it comes to hunting
cheetahs probably a little bit more than
that but it's all about terrain
experience and well anything can happen
you can watch a leopard hand three times
and it can be successful that could just
be luck it could be terrain it could be
the day but then you can also watch a
leopard aligned hand numerous times and
be unlucky
so they're not known to catch as many
prey or every single animal that they
see and so that is how the balance in
nature works if they're caught
everything their sort would just be a
bloodbath
the antelope are as well adapted to
surviving an invading predator predation
he is well he's making a move he's
probably gonna come out a little bit on
to the road where it might be a little
bit quieter for him to move or he's
gonna go through the thickets there
don't want to do too he's gonna come
around that tree I wanna do too much
movement
okay he's lost sight of the gnyana so
he's trying to move in just swath of
something running across that open area
that I was looking in before I'm going
to move slightly her just so it
other people behind us of you
me now anything can happen anything can
happen an injured leopard could catch
anything really it is all about the time
of day it's all about the the experience
of that animal and also about the
vigilance of the individuals that are
hunting or that are being hunted if
lipid comes across an injured animal it
can catch it quite easily but if it's
are very very able to catch things and
well even when injured are still very
very adapted what they do just trying to
move around yet redock one to influence
anything as soon as they get a view of
him I'm going to stop no I'll try to
answer their question a little bit
better for you you might see another
vehicle in the sighting they've kept to
the road on the other side their last
sight well I actually haven't even seen
that than Jana get a little bit forward
what a me his crouched down in the long
grass masters a camouflage injured
leopards the reality is is that an
injured leopard or leopard doesn't
require much in the way of speed
sometimes to catch prey if they can lie
down camouflaged like this individual is
doing and an unsuspecting animal walks
directly towards them they still have
the ability to pounce and to catch them
so that can happen in any stage not
necessarily every time and obviously the
lack of the draw meaning that the animal
has to walk straight towards the leopard
say my name Kangana has been injured we
don't know what happened to him it seems
like he's given up on the hunt you can
see his body language has changed
something happened all of the hyenas
coming in on the front there that's
what's going to happen I you know has
probably scared away at the Nala yes I
you know are well known that you follow
the leopards around the leopards catch
the food and the hyena try and steal it
from them
it's just in here he's gonna come and
say hello to us he's gonna give that
how's that hat oh he's gonna come and
give it the hyena a bit of a snore
there's a vehicle to the left there
there are in the road having a look
there's always fantastic interactions to
see hyena and leopard naina seems have
lost
- seems have lost sight of waiting Ghana
is but could definitely definitely smell
that he's here so he's watching the
movements of the hyena you know quite
often just growl and lay flat if I in it
comes close and a big man lipid liked in
Ghana has got a reputation and hyenas
quite often just staked yeah sure it is
all about camouflage our chair and this
is the leopards paradise this is exactly
where they belong
you'll see he's going to walk just
around in front of us yet and well are
we going to be hard-pressed trying to
keep up with him if he keeps walking on
this route it's him hyenas cackling
they're not sure what happened but in
Ghana had a little look well he's gonna
keep on wandering we're going to follow
him but what a marvelous
afternoon not sure Bonnie when the last
time he ate hopefully we'll get him
eating now I haven't seen him in months
his belly is looking very empty and I'm
sure he is hungry he's not moving very
fast on the territorial sort of
movements that they do have and I
haven't heard him call he marketing
quietly so as to also snatch a meal
along the way well folks we are going to
still be live for the next I think
hour or so maybe 45 minutes Google has
to see you there but please feel free to
enjoy your afternoon further and we will
catch you soon thanks for your comments
or questions and goodbye
welcome back everybody sorry about any
noise complaints from my lapel mic there
I think we are back on track now you
don't have to see if we can keep up with
the Juke moving through the thickets yet
I Nina is coming towards me on the right
yet he's trying to follow it in Ghana
because on this to hyena they are very
keen to snatch whatever he might catch
because well leopards arch here are far
more efficient in the way of hunting
then we record me hyena rawr it's
another one right yeah head is coming
right up to me listen I don't smell like
a leopard do I know I don't you smell
foul I just got a whiff of her she's got
the scent of him now she's going to try
find him we followed to Irena this
morning and we realized that we followed
them for a long way and they actually
went away from a sauna Sydney found
sauna pretty much where we started
following in the hyena so that obviously
found him really didn't any food realize
he didn't have any food sorry about my
head there I'm having some difficulties
with my microphone Andrew doesn't have
any food and then well decided to just
go off in the other direction these two
that are trying to ascertain whether the
Duke who they've picked up on his smell
whether he has got some food for them to
snatch
everyone's saying that they look very
curious well there's nothing accurate
more curious than a spotted hyena and
it's really interesting being back there
we go
get a two-shot chair rocked in Ghana and
that leopard just straight through their
hat wonder if you can get him some ganas
just through the back just disappearing
behind there and while the hyenas are
going to follow him and probably really
give him a heart um
they won't really do too much towards
him but if he's got some meat they might
try and snatch it off him but as I
saying
ting Ghana develops a very nice sort of
repertoire with these hyena a reputation
that they very well know and they'll
probably leave him alone even if he's
got a kill on the ground but if there's
two of them through them it might be a
different story one definitely leave him
alone they can't afford to combat the
battle-scarred veteran and well he can't
really afford to battle with them but
just through sort of aggressive response
or growling quite often can get away
yeah well this is not going to be ideal
way that I came in
hold on folks get out of here Rickson
has still got sites often guys we're not
going to lose him in you Tom see just
the problem being if he keeps up with a
southerly trajectory of movement well he
might cross south hopefully he will stay
it because as I said at the start of the
show him and his son are both movie
stars and they received the email about
us being on s ABC 3 again on Sunday at
6:30 p.m. and well he's in time he's
just he feels like he needs to eat a
little bit before because you know it's
a good bit of stage fright and a belly
of of meat belly of niala always seems
to do the Juke very very well as we've
seen in the past even if he snatched it
from his son you'll take it but anyway I
wonder how citizens getting on I know
he's in search of the aforementioned
husana let's go and see exactly where he
said I am still looking for Osama Steve
and congratulations for finding Tinga on
the other side
I'm sure Hassan is also gonna come out
somewhere in one of these areas so I can
feel that now the temperatures are going
down and this maybe might start
encouraging the cat such as wasana to
come out now and start looking for
dinner
we saw this morning he didn't get the
breakfast so now he's gonna have to look
for a very big meal
so this is the area where we have left
him and back again in that area just to
check if there is any other developments
but it looks like it is quite still
maybe he went to one of the water holes
in the area here so he was very close to
the border between us and the buffers
walk maybe he crossed over to the other
side
yeah they are very far apart at the
moment as the debt is much more to us
the eastern side and he is much more
toward the western side so they dread is
verify the moment a DJ or sauna is so
sneaky indeed but I will find him in
somewhere here he is somewhere he must
be lying down somewhere in these thick
bushes
so you can see that the bush is very
much peak at the moment so maybe this is
what is making it difficult for I would
spot him
so Elia one we saw the impalas here but
now the impalas are gone everything is
gone is so very much quiet maybe this
quietness is brought by his presence
not even the Squealer to give us a phone
call about way is it's just very quiet
so unless the spirits in this area feed
from the ground cause those ones by the
other side normally they see him from
high up and start calling the others
yeah I that is why I am trying by all
means to find him so that at least I can
have him for tonight
so is very shy for the TV show maybe
now unfortunately the animals they don't
really have a Sunday afternoon if you
check the Labour's the vast majority of
their time is dedicated for sleeping
during the day so it's normal for them
to just relax and spend all day just
lying down so coincidentally is doing it
every day
maybe somewhere this side but yeah I am
smelling quite a lot of elephant scent
so it looks like the elephants
we here meet those elephant is the one
that put him from this area
because there's quite a lot of evidence
as well as strong scent showing that
they have been here not very long time
ago
so now let's go back to the Duke of
Jummah well hopefully David we will find
him again he moved into the drainage
line they're very thick we try to get
our tricks and try to stay with him all
Rickson can see at the moment is one of
those ie nur so rickson's on the other
side of the strange line I've come to
the side of it if he moves through here
we'll hopefully catch him I've had him
walking through this exact path here and
I found him again just over here on the
road which was very fortunate I think
ours with sins oh then he disappeared
into this very difficult block to access
and well then out of nowhere he Sonny
was over here so that was very nice but
hopefully he's going to do the same
thing or if not okay sir Xing has heard
me and Tom come in North yeah copy
thanks Rex
okay so Rex is calling me in directly
here use this on the other side very
likely we might see that you just pop
out somewhere here it's probably gonna
either lie down because he's gonna be
annoyed with I Enoch because they will
follow him until he catches something or
he will run away from them I doubt he
will run I don't think it's in the Dukes
sort of nature he's just gonna walk with
that sort of regal ting gana sort of
stride some manana yeah yeah I can see a
vehicle see where we can spot him if
he's here we might be able to get a view
braixen is just over there with hyena
some y'all are just in the thicket this
is when your eyes need to really sort of
open to be able to view
so in the spots of the cats make them
invisible
well some of the viewers want to know
when is it more difficult to spot a
leopard when it's green or when it's dry
the interesting thing is that when it's
green there's far more cover which it's
tricky to see you can't see very deep
but the amazing part is that leopards
camouflage is so camouflage that when
there's hardly any occur any cover they
blend in so it's kind of designed for
both purposes really of blending in when
there's thick stuff and also blending in
when there's almost nothing I'll just
have a little listen to meters forward
and then you can at least frame up your
family of Nala here that are seemingly
completely unaware that there is a male
leopard somewhere in this area the hyena
will probably keep Rickson moving
towards Tenggara
luckily we've got him in the scene so we
can at least assist each other in the
movement but you can see how dense the
vegetation is the niala blend right in
takes everything in the leopards ability
to be able to stalk these animals out
here because of the thickets
hello Minami I don't know how long the
Duke can survive with that food while
they're akin lions and leopards or what
they call starvation resistant which
means they can go for about two weeks
without adequate meal but they don't
choose to they will eat regularly
they'll eat all the time they'll eat as
much as they possibly can but when they
get hungry so they're - it starts
changing and then what problem is this
when they get old and maybe sick they
lose the ability to hunt and that's when
they can potentially become dangerous
because when starvation kicks in an
animal loses its fear of all sorts of
things that might have once before held
in sort of a high regard or had some
fear of but yeah about two weeks would
be about the limit but they will eat
much more regularly
Reuven debt well we are looking for a
leopard but if you were in India most
certainly you'd probably be seeing a
tiger with those stripes there of the
Nuala
if only the knee allas could thoughtful
the leopards into thinking they were
Tigers and they wouldn't get eaten as
regularly as they do okay so I'm just
going to get an update from Rex in here
to see if he can see anything the Raider
is quite busy so just trying to get a
gap orexin Rex and Steve okay
copy thank you so patience pays off
follow the animals follow the hyena
follow Rickson okay
I'm gonna stay right where I am because
the niala all right yeah the same yalla
we've been looking at and they have no
idea so folks just bear with me stay
with us yet the Duke with his regal stay
and his twitchy tail is looking directly
at them and he's trying to figure out -
I wanted the baby or any of them weak
which one of them will be easy to catch
no I'm gonna lie down well there we go
maybe he can't see them that is
incredible he's not far away from these
nada and seemingly because of their
camouflage and their ability to stand
still
he has lost sight of them he knows that
they're here he probably heard them
little footfalls the drop of some dung
on the ground but he's looking around as
if he has lost them all together if he
comes straight down this game path
because we're we've got him here just
down in front of him there's a game path
that runs straight towards me and this
was the path I was hoping to to access
and when I came around onto the road
when Rex told me to come around onto the
road behind us on lead wood this is most
likely the path that he would have
followed straight through onto the next
road it's ease of access lipids Lions
rhinos elephants often will walk along
pathway as most animals in fact because
it's very easy to do so if you've ever
driven a vehicle on the main road and
it's very easy and I'll take the same
vehicle and drive it straight into the
bushes well it is not as easy to drive
through the bushes that it is - sick - a
well-worn path and when you are a
hunting leopard or a leopard that is
trying to cover as much ground as
possible in a territorial display you
want it to be as easy as possible or as
quiet as possible if you are stalking
and walking along a path makes it quite
easy to walk quietly pag make it I can't
smell him oh you're asking if he can
smell them the wind direction
is blowing pretty much towards him so
I'm not was not very strong very gentle
wind but I have no doubt he moved to air
his narcos of this family that he's seen
or he saw maybe he these are the
individuals that were spotted not so
long ago that I didn't even see maybe
the hyena caused him to run a little bit
but they have all got their backs to him
I'm not going to show them to you at the
moment because I don't want to make any
noise I want all of us to play art as it
shall naturally he seen be putting some
tension directly towards one of the
animals that has now moved a little bit
you see the intention on the body if he
picks a target we'll see him started to
crouch low and move quite quickly he
might be waiting for this group to split
up only slightly can you see them had of
a tricky game there they are that's what
he's looking through he's looking
through a thicket like that so that is
why it is hard for animals to be seen
Archer when you are as camouflaged as
any Allah they are they the Duke knows
they're somewhere nearby
sorry about my head again
and nothing like a leopard to when
everything is slowing down to suddenly
close his eyes and have a nap like
father like son let's see if Sydney has
managed to pick up on any tracks of
hasanah
it is live your son is still sleeping
somewhere here because I can't even see
the tracks coming out in and out is just
very quiet and I saw one of the steel
buckets maybe is that Stan rocky was
talking this morning in the very same
area but he aware is this is not very
far away from the gallic open maybe he's
gonna go for a drink by the gallic open
later on so there is quite a lot of
dangers in this area he likes to be this
is the drainage where he had the two
dead Nala's has some few weeks ago
so but there's not a lot of animals
which are carrying here by this drainage
you can see that animals don't really
like to come here but when the food is
cursed you will see animals there
because by this all the dry riverbed
they still quite a lot of green grass
growing on the side
so maybe somewhere deep in this drainage
yeah
I will be very happy to find him in this
area
the thing lie down flat
it's gonna be very difficult for us if
it's not at the open space
there is quite a lot of things happening
by the Christmas I remember South Africa
is consisted of quite a lot of different
diversities there is quite a lot of
different food eaten by the Christmas
Day a lot of people by Christmas Day he
prefers pork some they eat lot of goats
and some is when they are taking down
some of the their cows
if I is going to be a very big day on a
Christmas day but I will be here I will
be in the bush by the Christmas Day it
is an honor meant having a Christmas Day
in the bush with these wild animals
peace and quiet
so the ladies from the AFC they are busy
preparing some of the Christmas food for
us I'm not too sure specifically of what
kind but I have been told that is going
to be one of those best Christmas ever
biltong for christmas we do it quite a
lot of real tongues very often but for
christmas to those who are going out for
picnic year's biltong is guaranteed
because that is part of our snacks packs
you
you
I
see that is
right in the alphabet where these
maybe is not in yet
you
apologies for the network difficulties
these kind of problems do occur a lot
these days because the trees they are
now growing very big and they are now
having quite a lot of lot of lives I am
still tracking for asana here in this
area and still hoping to find him
somewhere in this area
this afternoon I am NOT relying on any
of the course none of these animals are
giving anyone in Collier but that does
not mean he is not here maybe he's
hiding somewhere here
very difficult this afternoon to get
hold of a David by the Maasai Mara due
to a heavy storm
apologies for those kind of technical
difficulties again so it's not only
affecting us is also affecting the
Maasai Mara
you
some of them they even go and play in
the rain like the elephants you see the
let's play and they like to sleep when
it's raining some that is when they are
going to sometimes the rain moisturize
distort the the graph is and when these
kind of animals are think the grass is
wet that is when they are going to be
having a lot of issues
for water
a cross spider I didn't copy your
question very well
yes I have got to be very careful here
now the trees the coming back heavily
and the right to maneuver in between the
trees this day is here the dry season it
was very easy I have been here on
several occasions and there was no
problem but now too much problem in the
same room
you
sorry for any tech difficulties but ting
Ghana has yearned for you all you know
back with us and we are with the Duke he
is walking along those prominent
gamepads and well keep going that way
sir you're gonna walk straight towards
us what a gym what a gentleman the knee
allas all moved off and he walked right
past where they'd been standing without
even a cursory glance it just goes to
show and that leopards won't expend
energy when animals are in groups unless
and the advantages are on their side
mainly being it quite dark or if the
wind is blowing if the wind is blowing
makes her much easier for them to stalk
closer but he's a very very well
experienced cat and so he knows that
trying to sneak up on a herd is a much
harder than an individual on its own and
very opportunistic they will take and
fight their battles when they need to
and run when they need to
so cosider you say his tongue is hanging
out well his bottom jaw because that
that julep is just so heavy and just
hanging down low isn't it and well he's
also quite warm it's still not cold and
he's been walking for quite some time
today for judging by the distance the
tracks have covered he um has walked
away from bull suck all the way down
it's not an enormous distance but for a
leopard with fur covering its body
walking in the heat of the day it is
quite something and well he's walking on
exactly the same a pathway and then I've
had him on before we're going to try and
keep up with him but first he's going to
stop and give us a very regal pose he is
not walking in a very territorial sort
of fashion
he is obviously very interested in
getting something to snack on the rain
was two three days ago now he's probably
done a lot of scent marking and well
this time of year it's very hot and he
maybe assumes it's going to be more rain
again hi bacon what's soggy skin well he
does seem to have a fair bit of soggy
skin they around
chest and his throat area but the julep
on the neck is part and parcel of what
happens with male leopards as they get
bigger it adds to their to their
strengths and to their size and I'm
going to move because I've got him
behind a little stick that is how you do
it in Ghana you know how to pose like
the best of them don't you boy
yes he does he is the man of the hour
these are the kind of shots that on
safari if you can get your guests into
these positions with a leopard sitting
on a termite mound while it is first
prize so many of the leopard sightings
I've had in my life before coming to the
sabi sands are just the faintest glimmer
of a cat disappearing through the
thickets or looking at a leopard through
the thickets with binoculars as it
stares back at you from a vehicle of
course and so the photography of
leopards in the sabi sands is
world-renowned and if you want to
capture leopards on camera and you want
to show and film and frame these
beautiful photos to put on your
mantelpiece well these are the areas to
come to obviously they are the reserves
as well but sabi sands is world-class
when it comes to leopards and well isn't
he a beautiful and beautiful boy
Kimberley indeed I think I said that
before already he is very regal but the
skin is loose around sort of the chest
area I'm sure he's lost a little bit of
weight in his age he's still a big
leopard but he definitely isn't as bulky
as he once was as with everything as we
get older we lose a little bit of
condition but he's still looking in fine
form and well we're probably going to
experience a little bit of a sawing
motion from him a little bit those of
you who don't know what sawing is I'm
not talking about the actual cutting of
wood but it's a territorial core of a
male or female leopard that sounds like
a plank of wood
being chopped with a bow saw but for now
we're going to try and follow him as he
continues to head on south unfortunately
he is on a pathway that I have been on
with him before where he might jump over
to Chitra I hope not
maybe he's going to do a bit of a left
turn somewhere over here we will just
follow him in the sea exactly where he
goes just sent mark to this little bush
a moment ago maybe prepared for one of
the nicest smells and sorry about the
branches they're cut one of the nicest
smells in the bush is leopard scent
marking hmmm I don't smell it it smells
like popcorn he's gonna rub his head
again in a moment or two against the
branch he's moving
stopping moving stopping he's not in any
serious mission at the moment listening
as it goes listening as he goes the
beautiful back side of the leopard this
is what I saw off a sign and the other
down foot was just his rear end as he
moved away from us easily to identify a
male leopard by the size of that neck
it's not SM it's not a bad rear ended or
a leopard male or female and the females
got very delicate what's he done he's
stopped like a pointer dog bloodhound
Tina's got a very delicate and sort of
elegant necks in most species the
leopard species of course and the males
have got this big thick set dewlap
obviously when they're younger they're
don't have it but there's still a lot
more thick set than the females
obviously size
yes everyone is saying he is in need of
a meal well I don't know if anybody
knows when last he ate needs to chat to
the butcher super-sorry their hat but
wassup guys cuz he's been up north for
the last couple of days so I wonder if
he has had a little snack oh this that's
what he looked at there was a water
bucket straight across over there that
looked at him and those of you who with
me a few months ago I don't even know
how many months ago he was on this exact
same path and he spotted probably this
exact same big male water buck and he
gave him one cursory look and then he
keep walking and water buck is way out
of his weight class the baby water buck
or small female most certainly I've seen
a male leopard with a couple of sort of
sub adult water backs up a tree that was
incredible to see never seent in Ghana
with a water buck seen tandy with a
couple babies but before we lose him he
pop I don't think he's going to stalk up
to that water back that's just that's
gonna be silly silly buggers
it's just on an ass Sunday stroll Wendy
let me just get up here and I'll talk to
you about it he's he's doing a bit of a
facial scrub again it's probably a very
common tree that has come across maybe a
tree that Tandy is rubbed on let's
quickly get in this sorry there we go
when do you want to know how we missed
it sorry folks when do you want to know
if if I tasted one of the leaves if it
would taste like popcorn well most
certainly not looking at that is the
sprite here it comes o up it goes onto
the branch so I'm going to art haft
afterwards to go up to that little wet
spot and give it a lick and tell us if
what it tastes like Kurt he's just
smiling at the back there he says why
not you only live once you only live
once and well how many of you can say
you've tasted leopard urine before I
certainly can't well I eat a lot of
leaves so it may be one of these days or
maybe I've already eaten some but I've
never tasted any popcorn II sort of
taste just that smells like popcorn for
what purpose
for what reason it smells like popcorn
it's beyond me to understand I'm just
going to stop here the Juke is walking
across the frame that's exactly what
we've seen him do a thousand times in
the past we are not far now from our
southern boundary with lower Gary and
chitwa chitwa but I'm just going to move
one more time to get on the other side
of him because well he's going to walk
behind the bush before the closing of
the show and that's just not how we
wanted ting gana we want you to stop sit
on this lovely branch for us and give
all the viewers a wonderful final couple
of screen shots this would be the final
display of the Juke as he walks only
metres away from the front of our
vehicle
he clearly seems to be hungry what a
marvelous achievement this afternoon and
we saw some interesting birds we found
the Duke David got rained on Sydney is
art and having a ball thank you everyone
for your questions comments we'll see
you again tomorrow
morning bright and early have a
beautiful beautiful day